[Music]
are they all solid
guys is there a problem lulu's not
talking until she gets her daughter back
season 23 of lawn or svu returns tonight
but let's be honest what has fans of the
franchise really pumped up and excited
benson and stabler together again benson
and stabler our lauren zema found out
marishka hargitay and chris maloney are
giving people what they want and then
some
whatever our chemistry was whatever we
did on screen you know in our svu days
together you know stuck with the people
i i guess it's our way to
interact with the with the uh fans in it
right on a different platform in a
different way that we can which we
didn't have back then
yep chris and marishka sent benzler fans
into a frenzy with this photo looking
pretty cozy they've been teasing a
reunion for weeks ahead of the law and
order svu and law and order organized
crime two-part season premiere that
drops tonight on nbc
liv
stay with me
elliott here we are benson and stabler
back together and i think it's gonna be
epic
so does that mean these two are finally
getting romantic stay tuned i'm teasing
it teasingly
we were with chris at a 92 y event in
new york for a q and a where the 60 year
olds well assets were a topic of
conversation i just changed out my work
out and i just started getting very leg
centric and all lo and behold
yeah
we also got a little behind the scenes
info on chris's behind from organized
crime's newest cast member guillermo
diaz and ainsley seeger between takes he
looks like he's taken a ballet class
like stretching out his hamstrings he's
very aware of it i think he loves the
attention
is the rear end as wonderful in person
as it is in the photos everyone has seen
on the internet his rear end is epic
yeah
yeah honestly i don't think photos do it
justice
[Music]
you